the opening scene features a farewell
party being held at the residence of an
astronaut named Luke Graham he is
celebrating his upcoming Journey to Mars
all of his loved ones and acquaintances
are present to bit him goodbye one of
his colleagues named Jim McConnell who
had been preparing for the same mission
is sadly unable to join Luke due to the
recent death of his wife the scene then
fast forwards by 13 months where Luke
and his fellow crew members have
successfully touched down on Mars
meanwhile Luke's other colleagues
including Jim are watching on from the
world Space Station's Command Center
maintaining communication with the crew
shortly after the arrival on Mars the
team comes across a strange bright
structure they suspect that this
formation may be an outgrowth
originating from an underground
geothermal water column which could
prove valuable for future human
colonization plants as a result they
relay this discovery to the command
center and then make their way towards
the formation to conduct further
investigation as they step out of their
spacecraft the astronauts hear an
unusual sound it sounds like this well
are you but they dismiss it as
interference coming from their robots
they then continue walking and soon come
across a towering formation resembling a
mountain the crew checks on their radar
and learns that it is metallic following
this they decide to enhance the radar
power prompting the sand beneath their
feet to shift for the first few seconds
the crew does not pay much attention to
this phenomenon and continues to record
the unexpected transformation in their
device but just then a massive Vortex
appears out of nowhere and launches a
sudden attack on the astronauts this
sadly results in the demise of everyone
except Luke and that's not even all the
vortex emits an immensely powerful
electromagnetic pulse that causes
extensive damage to the spacecraft's
electronic equipment once everything
settles down the formation finally
reveals itself it is an enormous
humanoid face indicating that Mars was
once inhabited by Homo sapiens meanwhile
a shocked and injured Luke somehow
manages to transmit a message to the
world's space station Tom long has been
here he said upon receiving this
transmission Jim becomes worried and
approaches his Superior Rey he proposes
that they immediately organize a rescue
mission however Rey is skeptical about
the idea as they aren't even sure what's
lurking on Mars perhaps Luke might not
survive the night after all Rey also
doesn't trust Jim due to his withdrawal
from the previous Expedition hearing all
of this one of the astronauts present in
the room Woody Blake comes forward and
defends Jim he says that the poor guy
was only caring for his ill wife and
that is something every husband would
prioritize moreover it was Jim and his
wife who extensively studied and
designed the Mars mission making him the
most knowledgeable about the planet this
argument finally convinces Rey and as a
result a rescue spacecraft comprising a
team of four individuals sets off for
Mars the crew members are Woody his wife
Terry Fisher Jim and a technician named
Phil oilmire the primary objective of
the mission is to investigate the tragic
events and secure the safe return of
Luke as they approach Mars's orbit they
realize that the mysterious interfere
still there they also noticed three
burial mounts which they assume to be
the resting places of their fallen crew
members soon after a magnetic storm
engulfs the planet rendering visibility
impossible for the astronauts but
despite this Rey sends a video message
granting them permission to land on Mars
Woody goes to share the news to Jim but
to his surprise the latter is watching a
family movie reminiscing about the
cherished moments with his late wife an
astronaut would never be doing that at
an important Moment Like This that some
Hollywood after this the team
Begins the preparations to land on Mars
but as they are doing so a swarm of
small meteorites suddenly collides with
their spaceship resulting in damage to
its Hall and causing an injury to Phil's
arm this incident also leads to an
atmosphere leak the crew swiftly
responds by conducting repairing
procedure diligently searching for the
source of the damage but the breach is
too small to be visually detected it
appears as if they are going to crash
but Terry comes up with an excellent
idea she squeezes a packet of juice
allowing it to float towards the breach
and seep through thereby identifying its
location with this Woody suits up to
venture into outer space and uses a
liquid substance to mend the breach the
very incident puts Jim at the brink of
asphyxiation but he somehow manages to
survive unbeknownst to the crew the fuel
tanks of their spacecraft have also
sustained damage due to the recent
Collision as a result of this when they
ignite the main engines the fuel leaks
into space and loads resulting in the
destruction of the spaceship hence with
no Alternatives left the crew is forced
to suit up and make their way towards
the resupply module that was left from
the first mission it appears to be
orbiting Mars in close proximity
unfortunately the circumstances are not
in the crew's favor as the resupply
module is moving at a slightly lower
orbit and a faster Pace than the crew
realizing that time is running out Woody
utilizes all the fuel in his rocket to
propel himself towards the module he
successfully attaches a tether to it but
loses his grip during this process
causing him to descend into the Martian
atmosphere panicked Harry disconnects
her tether and goes after her husband
she is adamant on saving him at all
costs despite the rest of the crew
saying that it's dangerous but just as
she reaches a bit further Woody
selflessly removes his helmet
sacrificing himself to ensure her
survival way to scar her for Life
jackass seeing this Terry Mourns for a
while before returning to her friends in
the next scene the crew finally reaches
the Martian's surface and begins
repairing the Earth returning vehicle or
Erv using the motherboards that they
have brought with them they also explore
the first spaceship in which their
former crew had arrived and to discover
that the living quarters are still
intact Jim heads to the greenhouse
section and is astounded to find that
all the planets are thriving as he
removes his helmet and catches a
reflection in a water-filled bucket he
notices someone holding an ax behind him
Jim quickly turns around only to
discover that it is Luke the latter
appears hostile at first as he has been
on this planet alone for months but when
Jim utters the names of his wife and son
he calms down Luke appears to be
affected by the isolation and the loss
of his crew causing him to exhibit some
signs of mental strain nonetheless he
manages to convey the discoveries made
by his team to The Rescuers including
the Colossal humanoid face he proceeds
to share that during his solitary period
he tried his best to unravel the
enigmatic nature of the structure Luke
then presents The Rescuers with his most
significant Discovery a recording
capturing the distinctive noise heard in
the vicinity of the the formation
through months of analysis Luke has
deciphered the sound as a
three-dimensional representation of
human-like DNA intricately mapped on a
spatial coordinate system he theorizes
that it serves as a distinctive
signature left by someone after some
hours of research Gem and his crew
learned that the mysterious signals they
have encountered are not merely
signatures but rather an interactive
prompt this prompt requires the input of
a missing pair of chromosomes essential
for completing the human DNA sequence
basically it appears to be a test left
behind by the creators and the previous
crew perished due to an incorrect
response to it Jim strongly believes
that they must fulfill the sequence to
pass this test as a result they deploy a
Rover to transmit the completed signal
using radar the plan works and an
opening materializes on the side of the
formation emitting a strange bright
light while Phil stays behind to repair
the Erv the remaining crew members
decide to investigate more as soon as
they walk inside the formation the
entrance gets sealed causing them to
lose contact with Phil not long after
they really realize that the atmosphere
here is similar to that of Earth so they
remove their helmets and start breathing
normally that was risky as they proceed
they enter a spacious dimly lit chamber
that astonishingly projects a
three-dimensional representation of the
solar system the crew members are left
in shock at what they are witnessing
after all these years of hard work and
research they have finally discovered
that aliens indeed exist shortly after a
holographic figure resembling a martian
appears and starts giving a silent
explanation it reveals that in the
distant past Mars was a thriving planet
with Abundant Life and water however
that changed one day when Mars was
struck by a catastrophic asteroid
completely destroying its ecosystem the
surviving martians were compelled to
evacuate their home planet in search of
new settlements they also sent their own
life forms to ancient Earth in the form
of microscopic bacteria over the course
of billions of years these life forms
developed into plants and animals
eventually humans were born and started
ruling planet Earth just like the
Martians had hoped this means that the
present-day humans and all the other
living organisms on Earth are actually
the sperm of Mars we are the aliens whoa
after the presentation ends the
holographic figure extends its hand to
the astronauts affirming that they
belong to the same species as the image
of the Martian figure slowly dissipates
it invites one of the astronauts to
their Newfound planetary destinations
meanwhile Phil somehow contacts the crew
and reveals that a deadly Storm is
Coming their way if they don't leave on
time they might become stranded or even
die here this worries the crew and they
prepare to leave but Jim announces that
he will stay he has decided to follow
the Martians on their journey to another
galaxy the rest of the crew members are
left in utter shock but they know that
it is Jim's dream to tour the Galaxy
prior to their depart prior to their
departure Terry presents Jim with a
rocket pendant that belonged to Woody
symbolizing their enduring friendship
Luke and Terry then make their way out
of the formation while Jim stands within
a cylindrical structure that undergoes a
transformation into a capsule-like
container at last he's gently lifted
into outer space Jim knows that from
this point onward his life is uncertain
and that he is completely reliant on the
Martians but after the death of his wife
he hasn't been quite the same either he
is getting to live his dream of
traversing space and if this is the way
he is going to die it is the right way
at least he doesn't have to wait long to
meet his wife assuming that aliens and
Heaven are real Jim getting greedy after
a while his capsule begins filling with
a clear liquid so Jim holds his breath
for as long as possible but at one point
he succumbs to the need for Aaron
breathes and to his astonishments he is
able to breathe within the liquid this
discovery brings a smile to Jim's face
as he realizes that he is in an entirely
new form of existence flooded with all
the good memories of the past he bids
one final farewell to everyone in the
final scene as the crew members are
taking off they notice Jim's Martian
craft fly past them at a speed of
hundreds of times greater than their RV
it is venturing deep into the vast
expanse of deep space the movie ends as
the crew sends their best wishes to Jim
hoping for his safe journey ahead
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching